[Applaudissements]
alors si je suis là aujourd'hui face à
vous ça avant tout pour vous partager
quelques constats et quelques
convictions aussi
saviez-vous qu aujourd'hui un français
sur dix est en situation d'isolement
soit plus de 5 millions de français
cela signifie qu'il ne rencontre
quasiment jamais vaut mieux quelques
fois par an seulement un membre de leur
famille alami a voisin ou encore une
connaissance alors cet isolement
il peut toucher tout type de population
mais certaines sont plus fragiles
il s'agit notamment des personnes âgées
des personnes sans emploi c'est un
phénomène aussi que l'on retrouve un peu
plus marquée en zone rurale et un plutôt
qu'en milieu urbain mais qui existe
aussi dans les grandes villes
puisqu'on trouve encore environ 23 % de
personnes habitant les grandes
agglomérations qui n'ont aucun contact
avec leurs voisins et des études ont
montré qu'il y aurait un lien entre l'
isolement et la précarité
ce qui veut dire que plus nos revenus
sont faibles
mon à de contact avec l'extérieur et
plus ce sentiment de solitude augmente
du coup les personnes se sentent souvent
abandonnés exclu voire parfois même
inutile et leur projection dans l'avenir
leur paraît beaucoup plus sombre et ce
lien entre précarité et isolement
il est d'autant plus alarmant lorsque
l'on sait d'après une étude de lille
c'est que 8,8 millions de personnes sont
considérées comme pauvres en france et
ont des revenus inférieurs au seuil de
pauvreté alors il ya plusieurs manières
de calculer le seuil de pauvreté
pour cette étude l'insee a choisi un
seuil de pauvreté à 1026 euros par mois
ce qui représente 60% du revenu médian
de la population et donc il y à 8,8
millions de personnes qui ont des
revenus inférieurs à 1000 26 euros par
mois il vient encore quelques chiffres
que j'ai envie de vous partager ici
deux millions deux millions c'est le
nombre de personnes qui travaillent et
qui pourtant ont des revenus inférieurs
au seuil de pauvreté 4,7 millions c'est
le nombre de personnes qui ont bénéficié
d'une aide alimentaire distribuée par la
croix rouge la banque alimentaire ou une
association caritative 226 millions
c'est le nombre de repas servis en 2018
en urgence à plus de deux millions de
personnes et enfin un français sur cinq
c'est le nombre de personnes qui ne peut
pas se nourrir correctement ni même
faire trois repas par jour alors
rassurez vous mon intention ici n'est
pas du tout de vous dépeindre un sombre
tableau et de vous laisser repartir
complètement déprimé
pas du tout si j'ai à coeur de vous
partager ces chiffres qui sont certes
alarmant c'est parce que je pense qu'il
ya aussi des solutions et des bonnes
nouvelles alors une des solutions parmi
tant d'autres mais qui paraît peut-être
la plus évidente
et bien c'est déjà la solidarité et ce
qui est chouette avec la solidarité
c'est que non seulement ça permet de
rendre service à quelqu'un qui en a
besoin
et en plus ça augmente notre propre
niveau de bonheur si si je vous assure
ça a été prouvé scientifiquement que le
dont l'empathie ou encore l'altruisme
permet de gagner en joie de vivre
alors il ya plusieurs études qui ont été
faites pour mettre en lumière ce lien
entre solidarité et bonheur alors c'est
par exemple le cas d'une étude qui a
réuni 6 neurobiologiste à
l'international donc issus de diverses
universités d'allemagne de suisse ou
encore de chicago qui ont pu démontrer
par imagerie cérébrale dont khaled dany
rl que la sensation de bien-être et la
générosité sont bien associer dans le
cerveau autrement dit la partie du
cerveau liées au bien-être et stimuler
lorsque l'on fait preuve de générosité
les anglo saxons eux il parle par
exemple de wang l'eau que l'on pourrait
traduire littéralement par chaude lueur
qui serait ce sentiment de bien-être de
satisfaction que l'on ressent lorsque
l'on fait preuve de
bonté et cette sensation elle s'explique
par le fait que ça libère de la
sérotonine cette fameuse hormones du
bonheur du plaisir que la même que l'on
libère
naturellement lorsque l'on fait du sport
du coup notez bien ça s'il ya des
feignants dans la salle arrêté le sport
vous pouvez faire un place un peu de
solidarité bon fait un peu les deux
importants pour la santé
en tout cas ça a été aussi prouvé que
offrir un peu de temps ou d'attention
ça nous permet aussi de gagner en joie
de vivre alors pour ça ils ont réuni des
étudiants ils les ont séparés en deux
groupes et le premier groupe a reçu la
consigne de réaliser chaque jour une
bonne action
le deuxième groupe ne devait rien
changer à ses habitudes et bien au bout
de seulement 10 jours ce premier groupe
qui avait reçu cette fameuse consignes
de réaliser chaque jour une bonne action
au bout de dix jours il avait déjà gagné
en confiance en eux et en satisfactions
de la vie pour le deuxième groupe vous
en doutez ça n'a rien changé et enfin un
dernier point qui est quand même aussi
important à souligner c'est que ces
mêmes études elles ont aussi révélé que
ce sentiment de bien-être
ils n'augmentent pas face à un surcroît
de générosité autrement dit un simple
geste peut suffire alors pour les
toulousains qui aurait suivi un peu
l'actualité ces derniers jours et qui
aurait vu ce jeune homme se faire
verbaliser d'une amende de 100 euros
pour avoir donné 70 centimes à une
personne dans le besoin
je vous rassure tout de suite soyez pas
découragés il a reçu la bonne nouvelle
comme quoi cette amende était annulée
face à l'absurdité de la situation
donc pas de problème en tout cas ce qui
est chouette
en france c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où l'on peut si on en a envie
faire preuve de solidarité
alors je pense notamment au milieu
associatif puisque en france il y a
environ 1,3 million d'associations en
activité qui regroupe 13 millions de
bénévoles et il ya eu entre 2017 et 2018
environ 70 milles création de structures
associatives
alors pour ma part je suis absolument
convaincu
aussi bien du lien qui peut exister
entre isolement et précarité que du lien
qui peut exister entre générosité et
bonheur gelé clairement expérimenté
pendant plus de huit ans en créant puis
en gérant une épicerie solidaire
associative près de bordeaux alors déjà
une épicerie solidaire qu'est ce que
c'est alors c'est un concept qui est
apparu dans les années 90 qui est en
plein essor depuis une dizaine d'années
et ce sont donc des structures qui
s'adresse à des personnes en situation
de précarité et concrètement ça se
présente comme un petit magasin qu'on
pourrait assimiler à un magasin de
proximité ou de quartier mais la
différence c'est que les produits sont
vendus beaucoup moins cher ils sont
vendus en général entre 10 et 50 % de
leur valeur marchande
ça veut dire qu'un produit que vous
auriez acheté 1 euros dans le commerce
ici vous ne le perd et qu'entre 10 et 50
centimes et les personnes qui ont accès
à ces épiceries solidaires elles ont un
reste à vivre par jour et par personne
compris entre 3 et 5 euros
ça veut dire qu'une fois qu'elles ont
payé l'ensemble de leurs charges
incompressibles à leur vie quotidienne
il ne leur reste plus que 90 à 150 euros
par mois pour se nourrir et
éventuellement s'habiller sortir ce
genre de choses
donc vraiment pas grand chose et donc
c'est déjà super les épiceries
solidaires permettent donc de répondre à
ce premier besoin un besoin primaire
celui de se nourrir mais ce qui est
intéressant je trouve c'est qu'elle
essaye d'aller encore plus loin en
essayant de prendre en compte la
situation de la personne dans sa
globalité et de l'essayer et de
l'accompagner vers une véritable
réinsertion sociale alors du coup
comment ça fonctionne en fait l'aide
alimentaire même si elle est importante
et nécessaire elle devient quelque part
un prétexte pour travailler sur d'autres
problématiques
alors déjà quand les personnes arrivent
à l'épicerie et bien une durée d'accès
limité
c'est à dire que le temps qu'elles vont
venir pour faire leurs courses - chef va
être limité en général entre trois ou
six mois renouvelable au moins une fois
et cette durée d'accès limité
eh bien elle permet de calculer
l'économie réelle que va pouvoir
réaliser la personne
en faisant ses courses moins cher et ses
économies elles vont être réinjectés
réinvesti dans ce que l'on appelle un
projet d'accès ou encore un projet
d'accompagnement pour lui permettre de
résoudre une problématique qui la
concerne donc très concrètement ça va
être
et bien le fait de payer mes courses
moins cher pendant six mois vont me
permettre de payer une dette de loyer de
régler l'impayé d'énergie ou bien
peut-être de réparer la voiture dont on
a absolument besoin pour aller
travailler
ça peut être aussi pour régler une
dépense de santé imprévus je pense
notamment aux personnes âgées qui
parfois ont de faibles retraites et ne
peuvent pas toujours faire face à une
dépense de santé un privé ça peut être
aussi pour partir en week-end avec ses
enfants parce qu'on a jamais vu partir
en vacances avec eux tout un tas de
projets variés en fonction de la
problématique de chacun et pour aller
encore un cran au dessus
les épiceries solidaires propose
également des ateliers collectifs alors
ce sont des ateliers qui sont animés
soit par des salariés soit par des
bénévoles qui sont eux aussi variés il
va y avoir par exemple des ateliers
cuisine pour apprendre à cuisiner un
petit budget des ateliers informatiques
pour réduire la fracture numérique pour
faire des recherches d'emploi peut y
avoir aussi des cours d'alphabétisation
lorsque les personnes ne parlent pas
bien le français
bref tout un tas d'ateliers qui tous ont
pour vocation de créer du lien social
et c'est aussi l'histoire de ce tablier
par exemple qui a été confectionné tous
ensemble donc avec les bénéficiaires les
bénévoles lors d'un atelier couture
donc on en a fait plusieurs on les a
ensuite vendu lors de différents
événements sur le territoire et avec
l'argent récolté est bien on a pu partir
avec plus de 50 personnes passé à un
cheveu de week end en dordogne
et voilà s'éloigner un peu du quotidien
leur redonner le sourire
et donc tout ça tout ça réuni et bien en
fait ça permet de créer un véritable
écosystème dans lequel la personne va
pouvoir petit à petit retrouver du lien
social et surtout retrouver estime et
confiance en elle alors durant ces huit
ans
j'ai réellement pu observer l'impact de
la solidarité et de la prise en compte
de la personne dans sa globalité
j'ai donc vu près de 960 personnes
certes bénéficié d'une aide alimentaire
mais surtout retrouver petit à petit
espoir et confiance en elle certaines
ont pu retrouver un emploi et la plupart
ont pu se réinsérer
ce qui est vraiment marquant c'est tout
le lien social qui a pu se créer dans ce
lieu de vie et du coup on y voit souvent
les personnes revenir même lorsqu'elles
n'ont plus accès pour les courses et
bien le continuent à venir aux ateliers
collectifs parce qu'elles y ont noué des
relations
pour d'autres ça allait encore plus loin
puisqu'elle émettent le souhait de
devenir à leur tour bénévoles pour aider
les nouveaux arrivants à l'épicerie
solidaire et donc je c'est un système
que je trouve vraiment très fédérateur
que ce soit pour les bénéficiaires
eux-mêmes mais aussi avec les salariés
les bénévoles et même de manière plus
large avec l'ensemble des partenaires
sur un même territoire pour lesquelles
même si on n'a pas forcément tous la
même façon de travailler le même axe de
travail et bien à un moment donné on se
retrouve tous autour de ce projet commun
et de cette envie commune d'offrir une
meilleure qualité de vie aux personnes
qui nous entourent et surtout quand
elles sont en situation de précarité et
d'un point de vue un peu plus
personnelle ce que m'a aussi appris
cette expérience c'est que parfois il
peut y avoir à l'intérieur de nous
plusieurs parts qui se confronte un
petit peu lorsque l'on se retrouve face
à des personnes en situation de
précarité
on peut se dire bah c'est bien beau tout
ça mais moi j'ai pas les moyens d'aider
tout le monde j'ai pas forcément le
temps l'énergie et cetera et c'est vrai
et c'est tout à fait légitime de
ressentir sa gelée bien sûr moi aussi
déjà expérimenté mais ça m'a amené à me
questionner sur ma notion sur la notion
de solidarité
par exemple vous à quoi pensez-vous
lorsque vous avez envie de faire un acte
de générosité de solidarité bien moi
pour ma part je l' ai souvent
directement assimilées à une aide
financière alors c'est vrai c'est une
forme de solidarité qui existe et qui
est importante le don ce genre de choses
mais c'est pas la seule
et parfois on peut faire preuve de
générosité et de solidarité en offrant
un peu de temps ou un peu d'attention ce
qui permet déjà aux personnes de se
sentir un peu moins seul alors du coup
ce que j'essaye de me dire maintenant
c'est ok j'ai peut-être pas les moyens
d'aider tout le monde ou au moins j'ai
peut-être pas les moyens de les aider
tous de la même manière mais je peux
faire un choix celui d'être solidaire à
ma manière en fonction de ma
disponibilité et de ma situation du
moment
alors parfois oui ça sera une aide
alimentaire une aide financière
et parfois ce sera aussi juste un peu de
temps ou d'attention
alors osons ozon de tendre la main
offrir des sourires et crayons
collectivement de véritables lieux de
vie où chacun peut se reconstruire à sa
manière à son rythme et se sentir un peu
moins seul que ce soit dans vos milieux
professionnels si vous en avez un jour
l'occasion ou bien dans votre vie
quotidienne vous pouvez toujours essayer
au pire la seule chose que vous
risquerez c'est de vous sentir un peu
plus heureux car comme le disait si bien
denis diderot l'homme le plus heureux
est celui qui fait le bonheur du plus
grand nombre d'autres merci
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]